hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're going
to be looking at a nice little tactic
called the x-ray an x-ray can be used in
a few different ways and we're going to
take a look at quite a few examples
today so you're familiar with some of
the ways you can use it but an x-ray
really is when you're attacking a piece
and you're attacking something behind
that piece or pawn depending on the
situation but you're attacking something
and indirectly you're attacking
something else so let's go ahead and
take a look at this example if you can
see here and we're going to look at why
but the bishop on f3 is attacking the
bishop on d5 and at the same time it's
indirectly attacking this pawn on b7 a
lot of amateurs if they're starting out
and they want to take away this defender
first you always want to take away a
defender so this Bishop is defending
this pawn on b7
a lot of beginners will take this bishop
on d5
and after the unite takes on d5 our
Knights going to capture on b7 but then
black can come to c3 and equalize here
in both sides have four pawns and why I
didn't really get a huge advantage there
but if we use an x-ray we'll go ahead
and take a look at this position again
we can actually first instead of taking
with our Bishop on d5 we can first take
Knight takes on b7 and we can do this
because again our Bishop is attacking
this b7 Square indirectly meaning that
if the bishop now takes on b7 then we
can capture with our Bishop on b7 and
now the knight on f6 hasn't moved and
we're up a pawn if black were to instead
take our Bishop on f3 that's completely
fine we can take with our King on f3 and
we're still up that pawn that we took so
it's very important to look at these
things where instead of always looking
to remove the defender notice what is
behind the defender in this case behind
this defender is the pawn on b7 so we
know that our Bishop on f3 is not only
attacking this Bishop on d5 but it's
indirectly attacking this b7 and
protecting whatever piece comes to this
in this case our knight is going to come
to this square on b7 so it's indirectly
defending our Knight after we take on b7
let's go ahead and take a look at a few
more examples so you're more familiar
with how x-rays can be used in your own
games let's take a look at this example
here and it's black smooth and black has
a nice little x-ray that he can set up
so if you want to take a minute just
pause the video and see if you can find
it yourself
but if we look at White's threats here
he has a few threats one he can capture
with E times d5 he can move up his pawn
to e5 putting a lot of pressure on the
black central control so black wants to
set up an x-ray to take away all of the
threats that White has in the center and
he can do this by bringing his Queen to
h4 which was played in the actual game
and here the Queen on h4 is x-raying
this pawn on d4 remember were indirectly
attacking a pun or piece in an attack so
if the white pawn on e4 would come to e5
or capture on d5 the black Queen can
capture on d4 capturing this pawn on d4
and at the same time checking the King
on g1 which would allow black to not
only take center control way but gain
material in the process so this is the
way that black was able to see the
position that white had and use a great
x-ray for his advantage so white cannot
continue with this plan so let's go and
take a look at a few more examples of an
x-ray take a look at this example it's
blacks move and see if you can set up a
nice little x-ray for black you can
pause it if you wants to take a minute
but hopefully you came up with the move
pawn to g5 if you take a look at this
before you can see that black has an
x-ray actually on the white King on h2
so we're going to try to exploit that
weakness that white has we're going to
start off by playing pawn to g5 in the
actual game that this was played white
captured on g5 and then black play pawn
to h4 and this does a couple things
white cannot recapture with his pawn on
h4 because then black can come in and
capture this rook on f4 he can't capture
with his rook because then black can
come capture on g3 check the King on h2
and then take the rook on h4 so what
we've done is we've noticed the weakness
the x-ray that we have on the white king
knowing that this pawn can't move
because of our pin that we have down on
it and so blacks going to have a very
very good game after he plays h4 just a
brutal move from white to try to counter
against so we'll go ahead and take a
look at a few more examples of how you
can use an x-ray in your game
let's take a look at our last example
here and it's White's move and see if
you can find a nice little x-ray that
white has and hopefully you came up with
the move Queen to b3 and what this does
is it indirectly attacks this pawn on b7
we're attacking the bishop on b4 so
that's the first priority that black has
is to make sure that that's not taken if
he tries to move his bishop away then we
can right away take with our pawn on b7
that pawn that we're capturing with is
protected by our queen on b3 if black
tries to hold on to his bishop with the
move let's say pawn to a5 then we can
use a nice little tactic we talked about
before and that's just removing the
defender with a move pawn to a3 we're
now attacking this bishop with our pawn
the bishop is now going to have to move
and after he moves doesn't matter where
he moves we can now take freely on b7
capturing
this pawn here and black cannot
recapture because we can take back with
our queen so you can see here first we
can't take with our pawn because then he
can capture but with our queen here on
b3 we're using an x-ray to attack and a
fin our pond that's going to be here
eventually on the b7 square we're going
to be up the material after this
exchange so these are a few ways that
you can use an x-ray a lot of times
you're going to be using it as a skewer
but you're going to be indirectly
attacking a square behind a piece or a
pond depending on the situation so
hopefully you guys enjoy this video hope
everyone learned another nice little
tactic they can use in their own games
if you haven't already please subscribe
to the videos if you haven't checked out
the website be sure and check it out W
WH s website calm and thanks for
watching I'll see you guys next video